all right ladies time for some more III
reactions I think we've got the devolver
conference up next oh wait
isn't Evolver just [ __ ] indie games ah
what a [ __ ] waste of time goodbye
forever
not doing this hey devolver use and I'll
let me into your parties and now I'm
here really I don't know maybe III
evolvers finally real publisher oh [ __ ]
is that a blazer or a trenchcoat I guess
user if you put that on we have to take
a shot yeah is that right yeah I like
trench coat mafia shut up
it's a blazer I got it's not a blazer
hey devolver when you gonna announce
Shenmue 3 what is this let's do uh just
do howl I'm a me again that worked out
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage two vulvar Digital zone Nia
Struthers hello thank you thank you
really hear too much
yes yes of course I know yeah
okay okay
already can we just come on you are a
professional journalist
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd like to thank you for joining me
here at the Dave Lang Memorial
Convention Center thank you this is our
first year of bringing you to the very
edge of your seats with the very best of
what video very games have to offer very
and I am very very proud to have you
here on this very journey with me
tonight tonight is going to be a special
one I've got a lot to show you I've got
a lot to tell you about much of which
will blow your mind up some of which
will frighten your extended family a
little a small amount of which will get
some of you arrested possibly even
slightly aroused all of which is
designed to subtly convince you to give
us your hard-earned money I hope you are
ready devolver digital fans for the
future of video games and the futures
future future
tomorrow's unethical business practices
today and with that check a look
it's hard to keep your attention these
days stay with me
good this is Rango City we need to go
down to see solving heart
psycho
killers
[Music]
her way out
kill some toys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
ladies and gentlemen Milo Lowrey so a
common thing I've been hearing from the
fans is that there's a certain level of
disconnect between their desire to pay
for a game and their ability to actually
pay for said game an open dialogue with
fans is deeply important to us and when
we hear that you're throwing money at
the screen and we look into our bank
accounts and that money isn't there well
it's sad pandas and suicide watch for
the accounting team and who likes sad
pandas I should very much like to show
you something
Margaret Thank You Margaret now do that
thing you're supposed to do at this
point in the presentation thanks a
bundle Madge we call it devolver digital
scream pay and we think you are going to
love it I'd like to give a demonstration
but I need a member of the audience you
sir I choose you
[Music]
all I need you to do sir
is to take these here redhot American
dolla dolla bills and throw them into
that screen to simulate a wholly valid
purchasing event oh what's that
isn't that interesting
we think this is going to be our big hit
in the physical space for 2017
go ahead shut those trucks
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and now a word prepare to fight
penis roars well that was awesome am i
right I bet you watched that game I bet
you want to buy that game you will buy
that game I believe in you buy that
[ __ ] game now that game isn't
available yet it is nearly complete what
if I told you though that you could buy
that game right now this second before
it was even finished old news right so
yesterday you'd you'd tell me Nina
early access has been a powerful tool
for developers and fans alike for years
you'd tell me that with your dumb little
mouth and I'd knuckle punch you right in
your goddamn throat because ladies and
gentlemen we have something even better
than that we are calling it devolver
digital earliest access and we think it
will be a revolutionary way to hastily
rush unfinished game content out to
consumers using a patent application
pending breakthrough in the twin
Sciences of heavy mu meson
sub temporal phase shift frame
manipulation and consumer psycho
commercial analytics devolver digital is
now able to release new titles into the
marketplace earlier than ever before how
much earlier we are talking point of
conception a developer thinks an idea
and bam
that shit's available for sale sound
far-fetched wrong clamp your gob you
[ __ ] [ __ ] devolver digital earliest
access titles are all ready available
now now now now now let's check in with
the developers of our most recent
earliest access title and see what they
think
check a look
hello I'm a sous la victoire tour -
naysha building okay hey oh eh oh hey ba
ba ba de Bourgh hotties are you Cyrano
Jonah akina's anoche en una sola Oh ten
days on end algo y Mochaccino my cigar a
moto Cienega attention I'm gonna miss
communication in translation Evolver
digital CD 1 will not be working at the
ball released access object together
back to Nina Struthers wonderful simply
wonderful wouldn't you say so devolver
digital big fancy press conference 2017
audience how about you audience at home
alright shut up now I have got something
that I think is a real kick in the nuts
Margaret what if I told you that there
was a way for you the unwashed masses
not only to complain about the games you
love but to complain about them so
effectively that it evoked real actual
change badass right the baddest shut up
edge now I will need a member of the
audience for this next one you you sir
this guy this guy is you look at you
imagine you are this guy and you have
some proper [ __ ] to say about a game you
really love but would totally love it a
lot more if it were different go ahead
fire away devolver comment created
content is the next evolution in user
created content it will make changes and
modifications in real time by pulling
any half-assed comments recommendation
or criticism directly from the game's
own user forums wish a game was easier
it already is dislike some minor feature
change done it's way better now want a
narrative based platformer about lost
love with 16 player online deathmatch
fire and wave brah the servers are full
of nodes with devolver calm and created
content it is you the player who is in
control and it is available now already
on every major forum message board and
life chat gift
everybody ladies and gentlemen what we
have shown you here today is only the
beginning
tomorrow's unethical business practices
today the future of video games in the
futures future
the future
to the futures futures
if you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh oh she's there ah I guess I'm a
burrito I want to be the best burrito I
can possibly be and win points I wonder
I wonder what I'm supposed to do explore
my burrito essence but hard on the
horizon that was encroaching fearsome
mashers oh no I'm a goner for sure oh
maybe I can escape
oh no I'm mostly intimate this is
literally monumentally frustrating I'm
serious as a monument over there they
just built it for me the most
frustrating part is that I exist to
sustain other beings who have no hair
purpose what type of purpose is that it
seems counterintuitive super self
concerned buried available now on double
for digital earliest access